the company behind the maker of Roundup
weedkiller plans to appeal on more than
two billion dollar verdict against it
during California yesterday found the
popular herbicide was linked to an
elderly couples cancer judgment is the
third since August against Monsanto's
parent company Bayer that involves this
product Anna Werner has been following
the controversy surrounding roundup Anna
good morning good morning the two other
verdicts were huge about 289 million and
80 million but those are just a fraction
of the more than two billion dollars
awarded to a married couple from
California the jury came to its decision
quickly deliberating less than two days
we've been fighting cancer for nine
years now it was caused by roundup for
more than three decades Alberta and Elva
pillage say they used Monsanto's Roundup
weedkiller to landscape their home and
other properties in 2011 alva was
diagnosed with a form of non-hodgkins
lymphoma
four years later Alberta received a
similar diagnosis and bones so they had
different types of the same disease
Monday an Oakland California jury agreed
that their cancers were linked to the
glyphosate based weed killer saying that
roundup was defectively designed and
that the company failed to warn
consumers of the herbicides potential
risk attorneys said Monsanto manipulated
scientific literature and attempted to
influence regulatory agencies while
discrediting scientists who connected
glyphosate to cancer
the jury saw it for what it was a two
billion dollars is a statement it was
the third multi-million dollar verdict
in a row against Bayer involving roundup
the first was in August when Dwayne Lee
Johnson was awarded more than 289
million dollars later reduced by a judge
to 78 million I spoke with him last year
what did that verdict mean to you the
verdict really meant to me that this
thing was not done in vain following
Monday's verdict Bayer expressed great
sympathy for mr. and mrs. pillion but
argued that leading health regulators
agreed
roundup can be used safely and that
glyphosate is not carcinogenic the
pillion say they want Monsanto to warn
consumers all this money is really lies
but our health would have been better
and had they been labeled we would have
paid attention to it the pillion say
they're still dealing with cancer
related health issues Alva has
difficulty speaking Alberta with vision
and hearing problems more than 13,000
lawsuits are still pending in April the
EPA reaffirmed its position that
glyphosate posed no risks of concern for
people exposed to it Norah I feel for
them mana thank you